uh it's always a pleasure to talk with
two actors i like about a movie that's
really effing good so you know it's a
pretty good day
um so i'm a huge fan of soderbergh and
as
most of everyone who reads collider uh
for both of you can you talk about
maybe what people might be surprised to
learn about the making of a soda bird
movie
ooh um i guess
for me i guess what was so surprising is
how uh
how certain he is of
what he wants and he needs for for the
project i mean usually you get with the
director you know there's a little bit
of uh
playing around you know looking at what
angles to do with in the scene
and and kind of where to put the camera
but
stephen does his research he knows
exactly what
what he wants from the scene he's almost
um he's almost
edited it in his mind already um
and so when you get on set the camera is
already there
everything's in imposition and then you
know
that that being said though he also
gives you the
space and freedom to to explore the
scene
and um to kind of so it doesn't feel
like you're trapped within kind of the
cam
where the camera is it but it's still
very
quick and um you know efficient
making a period film on location
during a pandemic was a a tall order
and um when you have somebody like
stephen
at the helm it it makes all of those
worries kind of dissipate and um
it just very much felt like we were in
in very good hands
um you know stephen has has a
well-earned and
and uh and accurate reputation for being
very
efficient uh and and that was definitely
the case
and it felt like uh a very uh
an excellent byproduct of having to
shoot this thing while we're all
worried if we're gonna infect somebody
or be infected or what what's happening
the fact that as noah said that there
was this person who was like
we're shooting this angle then this one
and then we all go home
uh and then that's what you did and that
was what the day was and
and we we very much uh worked under
under that uh understanding and it was
great and and and to make a movie that's
as complicated and complex and layered
and varied as this movie
under those uh restrictions was
a pretty amazing accomplishment what i
loved about ed solomon's script was
everything
but if i was being specific it would be
the fact that he was able to weave in
real history with these small-time
criminals uh for both of you can you
talk about what you responded to most
with the script what you're excited for
people to see
that that you're incredibly uh
correct on on that uh ed ed did an
amazing job with this script
and what what ostensibly could have been
sort of like a
uh almost like a raymond chandler uh uh
novel
turns into this sort of observation on
racial politics in the development of
the car culture
and and and corporate politics of uh
and espionage and all this other stuff
of of the development of this
very specific piece of technology um
it's just so smart
it's it's like like most of the stuff
uh that that that steven does it's got
it's got a layer of engagement and then
like four other layers that you can
engage with it
on and and that's as an actor as a
as a human being as a consumer of
of uh filmed entertainment that's it's a
it's a four-course meal
for sure i dropped history two years ago
so i can't give as much of a
historical answer but i guess to add to
that
there's also such
incredible emotion in it and um
and i think you know for
for actors for the actors that that were
in this it was
it was great because not only is it such
a i guess
political movie and with with
such history as it's based on real
events
um but it also had really intriguing
characters
and um really fascinating journeys that
these characters went on
again congrats uh have a fantastic day
can't wait to see fletch john
uh have a great day stephen